on this episode we do a Colin show
this is
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 200 on the ask gary
vee show it's a very special episode
Stefan show the characters around a
couple more peeps in the house in the of
course Brittnay is in the house
Andrews got the info Dirac on Facebook
Lyman and in the on Rule 360 video live
but Eponine I said yeah and he was
excited I'm sorry 200 we decided you
know episode 100 show clip from it
Stephon put it over here episode 100 we
actually you know brought a lot of you
together we did a live show episode 200
we're doing a call-in show so d-roc why
don't you show everybody on Facebook the
phone number that's right nine four nine
four two seven nine eight three three
call the askgaryvee show and get your
question answered India are you ready
for the call-in show and India why don't
you give everybody in the vaynernation
update you've now been one of my two
assistants for the last three weeks or
so Wow
well I'm asking you those questions so
what do you think give everybody the the
things that you're allowed to say what
are what's the biggest surprise so far I
mean you've been so close to the
ecosystem you've been a painter for how
long four years almost four years you
saw you've been a veiner you've been on
Team Gary Vee four right but now you're
in it you're closer than ever right and
so what's the what's the biggest
surprise so far I had no idea it's crazy
right like like it's crazy you didn t
Rock I don't think knows you know I even
though he's following me all day in
those scenarios he can't see the
parallel like that's the part that
people don't get the thing that's
happening that you now have access to is
the scariest [ __ ] of all because while
I'm doing the ten minute meetings in the
insanity this is collecting just
enormous amounts of pressure it's true
it's great there's a lot
and this funny all right 949 for two
seven nine eight three three : now i
will answer given - that's right that's
fine
facebook live call in nine four nine
four two seven nine eight three three
with your question and I will answer it
live on the show I'm excited about this
: now we just sit here and I excitingly
wait for the phone calls I was really
impressed with everybody waiting to call
I'm very very thankful Facebook oh you
look so funny so many of them are on
their phone so they feel like what do
they do like they like you know what I
mean it's so weird now right like what I
used to do this live streaming on
Ustream and have people call they were
like in their desktop and they would
just pick up their phone you know now
it's like all-encompassing in one device
so let me just see this one more time
and for the 2500 it's not working a lot
of people saying it's not working one
nine four nine four two seven nine eight
three three do you think we're getting
so many calls it broke doesn't go
through holy crap are we getting so many
not available
Andy what happened did we break it lines
got busy
exactly yeah everybody's I think we
crashed Whoville boys did we crash it
should we give this number no this isn't
we should give do we have any other
Google Voice numbers can I click this er
do mean break Google Voice why cuz the
Vayner
we can break anything this is gonna be
the best episode ever
hope you're enjoying episode 200 all
right
so yeah what's working it's all busy
signal's wait a minute am I like there
we go
look it was me maybe holy crap I think I
figured it out
I just think all right from Gilbert
Domingues Gilbert Dominguez - except -
press 1 wha
Gilbert yes hey Gary how are you brother
pretty good pretty good and yourself
tremendous what is your question well my
question is I have a upcoming
provisional patent on a warehouse
product I was wondering what I could do
to help prepare myself to becoming a
future business owner or entrepreneur or
what not so what are you worrying about
me I don't know what can I do whether
it's a book I could help prepare myself
cuz I'm gonna end up having to like
clean warehouses just to get my product
up there I was wondering I don't know I
have all this stuff coming up they're
gonna have to try to accomplish and I
just need some any type of business
advice well let me give you a good
advice you're gonna get nothing from
reading a book no books gonna tell you
like what to do what you need to do is
wrap your head around that you have to
bleed out of your [ __ ] eyes and work
24/7 365 there's no there's no advice
that I can give you like it's gonna be
about putting in the hard work and
learning the ropes
I'd also give you a huge advice go ask
questions to all your future customers
whoever you're gonna sell to go ask them
questions the best way to be successful
in business is to deliver for people
what they actually want and the best way
to figure out what they want is to ask
questions attachment spectated to the
user so that that's what I'm throwing
off of ok because this thing is it's
okay it's a dust mop and that hasn't
been altered since 1993 so I love it it
and it's for new attachments to it it's
like it is it
the future that month so listen I don't
give a [ __ ] if it's the future of human
beings if the customers don't eventually
like it or care it's not gonna matter so
just because you love your dust mop
doesn't mean the market does so you have
to have to go out there and really get
people to give a crap create content get
it into people's hands give away some
for free get it out there got it okay
all right buddy take care Gilbert all
right see what else we got here
what's a number nine four nine four two
seven nine eight three three why did
that work I don't know what it did yeah
I know but now like okay let's see what
happens this is so fun I love it we just
got to get the call mechanisms down
because the call-in show is though I
love this the calling show is super fun
like super super fun
I just don't know who's calling right
now like are we are we still like busy
like I love that we just try [ __ ] like
this I love the people that I can
actually watch this episode of you're
like what the hell happened here there's
like the Facebook people here why can
Gary just call me comments are repeating
why straight-up busy it's busy hmm put
the phone number and again nine four
nine four two seven ninety three three
yeah it's fine but I mean I don't think
that's what's happening I'm sure
somebody's calling should I just call
people should I just tell people on
Facebook to put their phone numbers and
just call people that you have the
numbers yeah all right just give me
numbers no great all right calling some
people this is for you guys an episode
200 because I don't make this boring we
haven't okay four six nine yeah eight
six you don't know the person is we have
to cover Oh Karen Carrie Carrie
the best is Anthony Anthony how are you
it's Kerry me Gary how are you so nice
to hear from you great to hear Brent
talk how are you conch
I'll uncom conch what's your question
brother so my question is Gary amongst
all the noise from all the snapchats and
all the tweets and all the Facebook
postings what catches your attention
what do you look for in value to want to
do business with somebody don't want to
connect with somebody you mean all the
people are hitting me up like just like
do this with me do that with me like
what catches my my attention right cuz
you talk a lot about Twitter video you
know I got my you know I got my
interview with Tony Robbins do a ya know
you I mean I was Twitter videos yeah got
it yep
so trying to you know land meetings and
connect with people what do you look for
what's the value to you amongst the
thousands of snaps and the thousands of
posts really didn't know what your
thoughts are
so unlike Tony Robbins and other things
that nature and all these other
executives I talked so much about
getting to people and I've helped people
get to people Allah what happened for
you that I get so much of that back at
me like this what you don't really
pissing me off Jab Jab Jab right hook
the amount of people that are doing
things for me that don't have the pure
intent in mind they're just doing it
because they want something in return
and then they're giving me things that I
don't want your [ __ ] jab and conch I
don't want the jabs that you want to
give me like I didn't want that hat like
I don't want it so like I think that um
I think that for what I look for is pure
intent and something that brings me
value of the moment for example let me
do something right now in episode 200
I'm about to send an email internally at
vaynermedia on Monday I'm adding a new
team member to my team called
distribution like I want to know like
this is things we've all talked about
maybe you guys don't but I'm gonna go
different route a minute bring one
person and their whole job for 15 hours
a day is to get distribution for my
content which means for 15 hours a day
you have to reach out to the 200,000
websites in the world that I think could
take dailyvee the askgaryvee show and my
articles and want to distribute them and
use them the way the Forbes and HuffPo
and others do it so you know I'm looking
for things that I need if somebody
happened to have been paying attention
to me and realize that distribution
mattered and tweet it out hey Gary Vee I
want to do distribution for you I will
guarantee you that I'll
eleven thousand websites in a hundred
days - distributor content that would
have caught my attention because that
was something I needed so whatever I
care about and I need if I see it being
communicated that's what I ring back -
conch that's all so Gary listen I
appreciate it so last thing and I'll
hang up is it's all about fundamentals
picking up the phone doing the research
finding out what value
yes value yes yes that's right thank you
you got it brother
let me come take care of nine four nine
four two seven nine eight three three is
the number you're gonna call turn off
call screening and see what happens
okay yes don't worry I'm not scared of
culture give me another number well here
Andy here's the key the number thing
number one thing we have to keep calling
because the number one thing I want to
do Andy is I want to remarket all these
cell phone numbers on Facebook to sell
them some more books but I do want to
make sure they seem content 8 5 9 3 2 1
1 3 7 8 I love how these people could
get random calls from other people the
vaynernation sorry Gary be going good
man who is this this is chase Fairchild
how are you doing I'm doing super well
chase thanks for being on the show
episode 200 thank you so much brother
yeah what's your what's your question um
so my friends and I are starting a
creative agency good I know a thing or
two I think I know a thing or two about
that and so we follow your work and we
read a lot of your stuff and we're
trying to get everything all our ducks
in a row before we start with launch
August 1st how do you think is the best
way for us to get over the fear of
failing at this cuz it's taken elite
we're in a we're currently an in-house
marketing department for a 21 chain
retail store I think you guys need to
you guys are taking the leap you guys
are rounding the troops and saying screw
this place we're going to do our thing
you've got to first decide here are the
ways to do it you do the emotional and
the practical when you take a leap the
practical is all
how many of you were doing it really the
three of you have to figure out worst
case scenario nothing goes well how long
can you survive on your savings or
you're willing to be entrepreneurial
ghetto got it yeah so the three of you
need to sit in a circle and you go India
how long can you last and India says 18
months Andrew how long can you last four
months
Andy how long can you last two years we
know we're only as strong as our weakest
link
god damn andrew's only got four months
so we have to talk about that number one
do you think that the three of you can
go without any sales for a year yeah I
will the good thing is we have investors
from the companies that got behind us
and they're like you try to have us we
can't have it take turn it a little bit
if it if it fails so great oh so now you
so it's that so it sounds like so it
sounds like you created the practical
version and now you just have to make
the emotional version too many people
and you know I've been talking about
this fake entrepreneurship if you're
scared to make the jump you still have
entrepreneurial tendencies you're not an
entrepreneur yet it's why you've worked
in a company in the first place you just
got to make the jump or not it's like
swimming either jump in the pool and you
go or you don't the end yeah that's way
and it wasn't like that's kind of much
because it you know we're just starting
this it's it's kind of new frontier you
know and dude you can't be dude don't be
scared nothing's gonna happen you can
always go back to the goddamn job yeah I
mean what is what's gonna happen I like
people to make fun of you like your
mom's gonna say you failed like who
gives a [ __ ] go try it doesn't work and
go don't care what other people think
it's the only reason you're scared yeah
whether it's your spouse your partner
your child your mother you whoever it is
eliminate those voices listen to
yourself and know that if you fail you
go back into it and nothing bad will
happen but if you win it's the greatest
[ __ ] that ever happened oh yeah cool all
right brother see you're welcome so why
are calls coming through while I'm on
the line but then not you think they're
coming through because you did the
unblock right that was your theory but
look what's happening they're still not
ringing nine missed calls what do you
want what you're just jumping in the
middle of my show I stopped seven
minutes why would you come in
what's up with your partner in crime
here we know that some minutes don't
come in the middle my show it alright
give me a number
Scott what is it four one zero six four
six two nine zero six
d-roc ask them hey guys what do you guys
think about the calming concept for the
askgaryvee show get a link next there's
a delay for your answers I want to plus
up + down for the askgaryvee show being
a live call-in show help me out give me
some feedback like there's a different
energy with this they love it right yeah
it's better it's good right this is it
we're gonna be a calling show India your
goose is cooked
Dante what's up where you from Dante
Milwaukee in the house are you are you a
huge Brewers fan Baltimore Ravens fans
are nice okay respond what's your
question brother look okay okay when you
think of the first one okay so this is
my place hey so not too long ago call
forensics pervert okay work with
elementary schools and I do workshops
that are pertinent to like forensics or
Speech and Debate it for familiar with
that yes and one of the hardest things
to do is to get into the schools and
provide those workshops yes because it's
really hard because it's politics and
bureaucrats and goddamn principals and
superintendents that all suck in or
average not all of you but the most of
you so like I really want to change the
educational system up so like first of
all let me throw a quick plug and say if
you're a elementary school principal and
you want to work with me hit me up I'm a
right hook and you know a little right
hook and and also though like how do I
get have some cake
contact Dante Dante the best way to sell
is to not sell the best way in the world
to sell is to have people come to you
instead of you going to them put out
content write an article on medium six
mistakes the superintendent makes then
post it and then spend 100 bucks on
amplifying the ad in Milwaukee in that
general area and I guarantee for
superintendents and teachers we'll pass
it on
it's put out content film court that's
stuff that you can film some of it will
be private and you can't the answer
Dante the full answer is making content
that's a gateway drug to penetrate the
decision-makers in school systems got it
yes how do I like how do I do that with
no money like can you write can you
write like I'm okay can you do it okay
so I would do well I would do audio
because I like the way you talk like I
would do SoundCloud posts I would post
them on your Facebook page you might
have one fan right now and then I would
reach out to everybody you know and ask
them to share it in Milwaukee and
literally ghetto
like I used to do it go to Twitter and
search people talking about your subject
matters and reply to them money is a
tricky thing
money tricks people people think they
need money you don't need money you need
hustle and or money if you want it I
don't want to hear you [ __ ] watching
Ravens at Monday night well actually you
do cuz you got to watch football but
after that you gotta stick to two
o'clock in the morning you can go to
Twitter search search the five mile
radius of Milwaukee and hit up anybody
talking about school issues you could
put out content rally up all your
friends all 47 people and your [ __ ]
auntie I don't give a [ __ ] and ask her
to share it and it just starts it starts
you got to start from the bottom okay
alright Dante get it see it by alright
doctor so YouTube 369 four nine four two
seven nine eight three three how many
people on Facebook live almost 4,000
people 4,000 let's go Andy eight three
two five three one five five
how we do there again please state your
name after the tone and Google Voice
will try to read there on Google Voice
to e4 Garcia
Gary monkey Bugbee hey guys what's up
man it's Gary hello well it's Gary
Vaynerchuk how are you good I guess
today to take take this off all right
can you hear me yeah I can hear you okay
great I was hearing the feedback from
watching it and hear my voice no worries
man Kieffer garcia greetings from
houston texas make up soos in h-town
what up I was introduced from a friend
of mine method 21 that told me about you
guys cuz I was starting up my business
and definitely is booming a fire
underneath me so I started up unison
Industrial Solutions ok sales consulting
company I was mentoring some kids from
the University of Houston that didn't
have any direction when they finished
their their degrees so what I started
doing was introducing them to trade
shows taking them out Higgens to the
some of the networking events giving
them a crash course at oil and gas
yep that men and this would be a great
business to start so you so side work so
real quick my man this is the askgaryvee
show so I gotta ask what's the question
I appreciate the context and I don't
want to be a douche I want the question
though obsessed with the question how do
you keep it together I wanted it you ask
suggestions of a DRN soft word that
you'd want to keep everything together
yep I want to kind of give you an
overview yeah and I appreciate all the
different pieces together and then maybe
if I can do that yeah look at me with a
white label at the RM got it so you
actually want to build a CRM for people
that do stuff like you or you want to
figure out what's the difference between
an excel sheet or Google Doc that's free
and Salesforce and the answer is
probably both right so I mean are you
trying to I mean are you really saying I
don't want to do a service business I
want to build a SAS business and create
a product no i consulting for more than
gas and so i wanted to be able
to cultivate a farm teach these kids
that way they have some direction and
then maybe even while they're going to
school give them practical application
of what they're learning okay
and then give them a crash course in the
oil and gas so that they have a goal in
mind for their education and so I'm some
unstably hire them okay and so the
question is how do you organize their
information to be most efficient or what
I want to make sure I understand the
question
correct so it would be keeping keeping
all the students together yeah be able
to categorize them and be able to find
out what they're studying whether it's
engineering I do honestly yeah honestly
like Salesforce or Google Docs like it's
not super complicated those are two
plays okay yeah what about a label CRM
do you have any suggestions on white
label I meaning you want to create one
or who's out there that white label it's
like what do you want to do with the
white label CRM I want on there so what
you're asking I want to be able to give
students the regatta with oil and gas
yeah I don't I don't I don't I don't
know but the good news is there's
something way better than the askgaryvee
show you should write this down you got
a pen and paper ready ready um gee oh
gee al got it that's it when you want
information my friends Google is better
than me you know if you want context I
might be better respect yep thanks Mandy
thank you all right good experiment I
got it one more Scott dude he tried to
call but he called back to voicemail I
just got it I don't know I once got to
feel the pain okay that's my religion
Scott Scott we're sorry Andy does
everything show any space all right fun
experiment I gotta go I just want to
take a few seconds to thank all of you
for allowing me to get to episode 200
it's fun because episode 200 I think you
can see little clunky we're trying to
figure it out but there's clearly the
pieces d-roc what did you see like
people like the picnic push Pete there's
the pieces the foundation of some sort
of interesting next chapter of the
askgaryvee show where we finally get rid
of each other riff Raff's over here we
just get rid of them they're finished
technology is taking over them we gotta
figure with that
you have a new job then much is more
intense than you think anyway I want to
thank you guys so much for supporting
this show supporting me watching CNBC
the other night appreciate that the
snapchat the dailyvees all that the Iraq
and I are gonna be back to filming those
so that should be fun and thank you so
much for being part of this journey I
appreciate you tremendously and we will
be back for episode 201 shortly probably
Monday right okay Monday it'll be
interesting are we gonna go live Q&A or
are we gonna go back to that actually
that's the question today give me the
direction you'd like to see episode 200
through 300 you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
how are you pretty good I just noticed
you're running up I'm not wrapped up I'm
finished you're finished but I got good
news I'm gonna sneak in this question
for you so what is it this has to be the
fastest question the answer of all time
nope so when when do you decide if you
start a business okay I have two right
now one of them I kind of dropped on
soon as my partners don't really have
the drive to keep going on yeah at what
point do you decide to throw in the
towel and how exactly you know if you
ever had any situations where you've
kind of I've been in a lot of businesses
where I was the minority partner non
driver of the businesses that have
failed and the way I do it is I just
take it for a loss and I shock it up you
try to sell it for whatever scraps it's
worth or sell it back to your partners
that are running it or you just you walk
away it's a zero it's over it's done or
if you feel like crap and I work seven
years it's worth real money you sell it
and you sell it from a non leveraged
position which means you'll get less
money for it but it's still okay because
clearly by the tone of your voice and
the fact that you have that passion for
number one you've got to let it go yeah
well you know you work 90 hours a week
in it it gets tough to spread energy
please yeah the real question is how
much money
you gonna lose and are you willing to
lose it and a lot of times what people
don't realize is they don't want to lose
the $40,000 or the $5,000 or 500 million
dollars and they could make seven
hundred million or five thousand times
for like if you get back your 40 hours
from that thing or 30 or 20 or even ten
you might make more money deploying
against the thing you care about than
the money you left on the table so X Y Z
you know you're leaving a hundred
thousand that you're giving up and
you're like [ __ ] I can't give that up
but what you don't realize is the 18
hours back and the happiness and not the
drain in the emotional drain of a
hundred hours a week on that other thing
allows you to make 120 thousand on your
nuegaike yeah that's exactly where I'm
at is you know how much how much more
money can I make you know the attorney
loses it for me um you know and yeah
yeah yeah no it's still really clear
never start business with friends either
no not true always start businesses with
friends if you can pull it off
yeah just well listen I mean listen it
didn't work out it's a life lesson right
but um you know but you know that's the
[ __ ] game baby this is
entrepreneurship yeah yeah I know for
sure every uh every